jean cadets gilbert marion ont plus de
80 ans toujours bon pied bon oeil et un
souvenir précis de ce qui s'est passé
ici près du centre de montbéliard le 11
juin 1968 donc bello il est donc tombé
ici à là après que les grévistes s'est
enfoncé la porte hier le command car de
crs qui était derrière ce qui était dans
pris peur et ils ont tiré
pierre beylot 24 ans tombe sous une
balles des forces de l'ordre
un peu plus tard henry blanchet chute
d'un mur et se tue 1 2 morts parmi les
ouvriers peugeot lourd bilan pour
déloger des manifestants de lusine mai
68 à sochaux a commencé plus tard
qu'ailleurs le vin exactement jour où la
grève avec occupation est votée avec un
symbole fort pour marquer la prise de
pouvoir par les ouvriers
voilà c'est un drapeau qu'on a hissé le
premier jour donc de l'occupation lundi
20 mai drapeau rouge
le drapeau rouge en a descendu le
drapeau jaune et bleu et on y est hissé
le drapeau rouge qui est donc le symbole
quand même d'aider des luttes la commune
de paris qui restait toulouse la grève
et qui restait tout le long de la grève
absolument aujourd'hui que reste-t-il de
la mémoire de ces événements
50 en un demi siècle une éternité
en 1968 il y avait 25 mille salariés
chez peugeot à sochaux
ils sont huit mille deux cents
aujourd'hui en production près d'un
ouvrier sur deux est intérimaire de
l'avis de tous les responsables
syndicaux les revendications ne manquent
pas mais la capacité à mobiliser n'est
plus celle de 1968 l'odeur tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours et
contrats à fonds que l'intérimaire ci
fait grève où il va se mobiliser pour
une action ou pour revendiquer ses
droits ou à voir or de nouveaux acquis
au niveau des droits
il peut avoir une rupture de contrat
être menacé d'avoir un ou non
renouvellement de contrat voilà c'est ça
c'est ça qui pose celle chapelle
chantage à l'emploi qui fait que les
salines se mobilise plus les
revendications salariales elles sont
toujours actuelles de nos jours on peut
pas se permettre d'avoir des salariés
qui travaillent en ligne pour un smic on
sent heureux avec des horaires décalés
des week-end perturbé tous les mois
aucune organisation familiale qui peut
se faire aucune activité familiale qui
peut se faire du fait de l'organisation
de l'entreprise devant l' usine pas
facile d'aborder les opérateurs bonjour
c'est france 3 proposait de trois
questions juste une minute non mais
c'est pas sûr en entrant comme en
sortant beaucoup sont pressés et peu
désireux de consacrer deux minutes pour
répondre à des journalistes
pourtant la question ne partent pas sur
les conditions de travail aujourd'hui
mais bien sûr ce qui s'est passé ici il
y à 50 ans on ne ment jamais entendu
parler mais après eux
on entendit les tirs mais on n'en sait
pas plus on en parle un petit peu dans
les usines de salah ça va être les 50
ans non je sais qu'il ya eu pas mal de
manifestations à cette période là qui
oui comme vous le disiez quelques
quelques dizaines de morts me moreau et
après pas plus que ça ce qui a changé
c'est aussi le niveau du chômage à
populations égales environ six fois plus
aujourd'hui qu'en 1968
l'emploi est rare donc précieux on parle
beaucoup de flexibilité de compétitivité
entre les entreprises
donc c'est toujours plus plus plus plus
avec moins de matériel moins de
personnel concerné plus en plus dur
aussi
même entre salariés à une compétitivité
aussi puisqu'on doit paraître meilleur
que l'autre façon anarchique si on veut
rester plus longtemps que l'autre
comme tous les ans une cérémonie de
commémoration aura lieu le 11 juin
devant le monument aux victimes
mais cette année les syndicats ont prévu
rencontres et expositions pour donner à
ce 50e anniversaire un relief
particulier